at this time of the day children in El
jalazone refugee camp should be at
school but they haven't been in class
for 100 days
these youngsters are among 45
000 students studying at the schools
funded by the U.N relief and works
Agency for Palestinian refugees
its employees in the occupied West Bank
have been on strike calling for better
salaries
banner last wore her school uniform in
March the summer break is coming up and
she's afraid of falling behind we hope
that the U.N agency responds to workers
demands and end the strike our future is
at risk we have the right to go to
school and learn like other children in
the world
Healthcare centers have closed and
rubbish collection Services have stopped
refugees say they understand the reasons
behind the strike and support workers
but they're the ones paying the price
we want clean air at least dogs cats and
flies hang around the garbage the smell
is really bad when neglected left in
unsanitary conditions this is the second
time this year employees are striking
they say the agency has backtracked on
its promises to review their salaries
never in the history of the United
Nations relief and works agency have we
had a strike as long as this one 100
days without services in 19 refugee
camps this is a catastrophe
the U1 relief and works agency was set
up in 1949 a year after hundreds of
thousands of Palestinians were forced
from their homes when the state of
Israel was created it has been providing
health education and Social Services to
5.9 million people nearly 1 million of
them here in the West Bank what was
supposed to be a temporary Mission until
a just and Lasting solution could be
found has been prolonged for seven
decades Palestinians here say that the
agency is gradually abandoning its
duties towards refugees
Services have been scaled back for years
the agency says it is facing a deep
financial crisis and cannot afford to
raise wages
we started this year with more than 70
million dollars in deficits some
countries told us they will decrease
their financial contribution this would
definitely limit our ability to provide
services
Palestinians say they've been refugees
for decades and now they're being
overlooked as the International
Community is focused on more recent
crises
Bank